The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Well, OK.
So I thought I would, as
last time, before Quiz 1
and now before Quiz 2,
I thought I would just
tell you what the topics
of the four problems are.
Remember that trusses
are still to be reviewed,
and of course the fun
was to find mechanisms,
to find solutions to Au=0, in
the case when the truss was
unstable.
So you can guess
that I'll probably
pick an unstable truss.
And ask for mechanisms.
Then maybe the key problem
for this third of the course
is finite elements.
That idea, and
finite elements we've
really only done
in one dimension,
so-- And particularly linear
hat function elements.
So you see what's not
included there is like cubics.
I mean, those are really
great finite elements,
but maybe not so
great for an exam.
So 1-D is enough;
linear elements
are enough to do on an exam.
And then questions
three and four,
so this one will be
weighted more heavily.
Then questions three
and four are the topics
that we've been doing
the last week, two weeks.
And I realize we
haven't had full time
to digest them, to work
a whole lot of exercises.
So those will be, right
now they're too simple,
my questions on those topics.
Three and four, I'll try to make
them a little harder for you.
But I might not succeed.
So, anyway.
There we go.
So I just felt we can't talk
about a course in applied math
without dealing with these
topics in vector calculus
that lead to Laplace's equation.
But my heart is
really in solving
Laplace's equation or Poisson's
equation by finite differences.
That'll be today, or
by finite elements,
that'll be Wednesday
and probably Friday.
So this is like the core
of the computational side,
but we had to do
this preparation.
And then you know
that Peter kindly
changed his weekly review
session to Tuesday,
I think it's Tuesday at noon;
you could look on the website.
So Peter will be a Tuesday
review and then regular, that's
me, on Wednesday.
And then the exam, I think,
is Wednesday evening.
I think, yeah.
Let me just do a review.
Oh, Peter sent me a note about
a question on an old exam.
I think it was 2005,
question three.
I think it was 2005
Peter said he didn't understand,
at all, the solution to 3c.
Nor do I. I think
somehow, I think
there was a little confusion in
that, and the answer in there
is the answer to a
different question.
Forget it.
Having looked at
this one, a and b
are worth looking at in this
div, grad, potential, stream
function world that we're in.
Those are typical
exercises in that area.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Oh, good question.
Yes.
Thanks for reminding me.
So, solutions to the homework
that you're practicing with.
If anybody has typed
up solutions or could,
we'll post them right away.
So I'll just hope for an
email from somebody who solved
some or all of those problems.
And of course you'll
see me again Wednesday.
But that's an
invitation for anybody
who worked through
those homeworks
that I'll never collect.
The current homework.
OK, thanks for that.
Other questions about
the exam, and then you'll
have another chance
Wednesday to ask about that,
so those are the topics.
OK.
And before I get to the
fast Poisson solvers
there's so much about
Laplace's equation to say
and I think it still
remains to write
Green's formula on the board.
And that's part of the big
picture of Laplace's equation
is to see this.
So we have double integrals
now, that's the difference.
But we're still
integrating Au against w.
So Au is the gradient
of u; w is w_1, w_2,
and this is now for
any u and any w,
so I want the inner product.
Of the gradient of u with any
w, so this is like the Auw part,
so the gradient of u, that
would be a du/dx times the w_1.
And a du/dy times w_2.
dx dy, that would be.
So inner products, if
I'm in two dimensions,
inner products are
integrals, of course,
if I'm dealing with functions.
So this is like
the Au against w.
Inner product.
Au is those two pieces, w is
those, there's the dot product.
And now the key idea behind
what Green's formula is about,
what we use it for in 1-D,
is integration by parts.
So an integration
by parts is going
to produce a double
integral in which-- So I'm
just sort of thinking
through Green's formula.
Of course, we could just say
OK, remember that formula.
But you want to just see it
as an integration by parts.
See how it evolved.
And then we can think.
So I plan to do
integration by parts,
that x derivative will get
taken off of u and put onto w_1.
So I'll have u*dw_1-- Oh,
there'll be a minus right,
from the integration by part.
u will multiply minus dw_1/dx,
so that was this guy
integrated by parts.
Now this one
integrated by parts,
a y derivative is coming
off of u and onto w_2.
So that'll leave me with u times
dw_2/dy with the minus sign.
That comes also from that
integration by parts.
And then there's
the boundary term.
So there's the term which--
Now the boundary of the region
is the curve around it instead
of just the two points.
And what do we see in
the integration by parts?
Well, from the boundary
term we expect a u
and then the key point
is it's w dot n ds.
It's the normal component
of of this vector w.
Because we're looking, well,
that's just what it is.
So that's Green's formula
written out in detail.
And this is the
formula that tells us
that here, if this was
A, A being gradient,
on the left side I'm seeing
grad u in a product with w,
and over here I'm seeing
the inner product of u with,
what's that?
If I look at minus, if I
have this quantity there
that's in parentheses,
what's its name?
It's the divergence.
It's minus the divergence of w.
Plus the boundary term.
So this is why I allowed
myself this gradient transpose
equal minus divergence to see
that if A is the gradient then
A transpose will be
minus the divergence.
And this shows how
that-- just sort of shows
you the integration by
parts that makes that true.
So, you know there's so many
integral formulas in this world
of vector calculus.
But this is like, one to know.
And actually, if
you want to know,
OK what about the details,
where did that come from?
This actually turns
out to be, and the text
will make it clear, is
the divergence theorem.
The divergence theorem gives
us this, this, exactly this,
so the divergence theorem
applied to the vector field u
times w.
It turns out if I apply the
divergence theorem to that,
then I get a whole lot of terms
from the divergence of that,
and they are these.
And then I get this
for the boundary.
The flux out.
OK, so.
I just didn't want to leave the
subject without writing down
the central thing.
What does this tell us, then?
I have a region.
In that region I have Laplace's
equation or Poisson's equation.
Say Poisson.
On the boundary.
Now, this is the final
thing to ask you about.
What are suitable
boundary conditions
for this problem in 2-D?
Right?
In 1-D, by now we know
boundary conditions.
We know the main ones.
There's fixed, where u is given.
Or there's free where
the slope is given.
Now, what do we do here?
So this is where we used to be
in 1-D. That's a straight line.
Not perfectly straight
but anyway, straight line.
So 1-D there are only
two boundary points.
The normal vector goes
that way, and that way.
This is the n in this formula.
I think if I just wrote
ordinary integration
by parts it would
look just the same
and my boundary
reduces to two points.
Here my boundary's the
whole curve around.
So what corresponds to
fixed boundary conditions,
and what corresponds to
free boundary conditions?
So I want the-- What
corresponds to fixed,
those are the ones that
named after Dirichlet.
Other names?
Or the rest will
be free, those are
the ones named after
Neumann, and those
are what we call natural
boundary conditions.
So I haven't-- Just ready
to finish this story here.
What are the possibilities?
Well, in each we could have part
of the boundary could be fixed.
Part could be free.
So fixed would mean say
some other boundary,
let me call this part
of the boundary fixed.
So the temperature,
for example is fixed
on this part of the boundary.
So this would be like, and this
might be the whole boundary.
It might be fixed
on the whole one,
but I'm now allowing
the possibility
that we have here a fixed part
and here we have a free part.
In fluids, here we have
fixed corresponds to,
like, there's some
obstacle there.
Some wall.
Free is where the fluid is
coming in or flowing out.
So there it's a
velocity condition.
OK, so fixed conditions, these
Dirichlet ones, will be like,
tell me what u is, u is given.
On this part.
So on part of the
boundary, or possibly all,
I could be given u=u_0.
It could be zero, as it often
was in 1-D. Often just took u
to be zero.
Now, what I'm asking
maybe for the first time,
is what's the free
boundary conditions?
Do we prescribe w=0 on the
free part of the boundary?
Is w=0 the correct
free condition?
Or w=w_0?
If we wanted to allow
it to be non-zero.
That would sound right, right?
u on one side, w on the other.
But now we're in 2-D.
u is still a scalar.
That's fine.
But w is now a vector.
So if I was to prescribe w
on this part of the boundary,
I'm giving you two
conditions, not one.
And that's not good.
I can't give you more than
one boundary condition.
And the clue is there.
It's w dot n, it's
the outward flow.
That you could prescribe.
You can't say in advance what
the tangential flow should be.
So the free conditions
would be like w dot n,
which is of course,
since w is v,
we have Laplace's equation here
with c=1 in between w and v,
so this is the gradient
of u dot n, grad u dot n,
and it's sometimes written, the
derivative of u in the normal
direction.
And that we can
prescribe as some w_0.
Oh, I don't like to say
w_0 because w_0 makes
it sound like a vector
would be allowed,
and that's the whole point here.
We give one boundary condition;
we either give u or w dot n.
So let me give it some
different name, like F.
So.
I'll just ask one more
question to bring this home.
And then I'll get on to the fun
today of fast Poisson solvers.
What was the deal on in 1-D
when we had free-free boundary
conditions?
What was the deal in one
dimension when we had
free-free boundary conditions?
Both conditions were
slope conditions. u'=0.
What matrix did we get?
What was different about that
matrix, the free-free case?
I'm always looking back
to 1-D because that's
the case we really understood.
What was the the problem
with the free-free matrix?
It was singular.
What was its name?
Was K, was it?
You remember the first day of
class, the unforgettable four
matrices?
So this was fixed-fixed,
fixed-fixed.
This one was, you could tell
me better than I can remember.
T was free-fixed.
And that was still OK.
By OK I mean it was
still invertible.
What was B?
Free-free, that's
what I'm looking at.
And the problem with
free-free-- And then this
was periodic, that's
Fourier stuff that's
the next part of the course.
But the point is that this
free-free was singular.
Right?
And it'll be the same here.
If the whole boundary
is free, then I've
got a singular problem.
If I've got a whole
boundary that's free,
yeah actually I'll
just put it here.
Suppose I have Laplace's
equation, zero,
and suppose I make
the whole all free.
So grad u dot n is zero
on the whole boundary.
So it's like solving Bu=0.
And the point is that
that has solutions.
You remember, what
was in the null space
of B, this free-free case?
Bu=0, for what vector?
Our favorite guilty vector.
It was constants.
Right, all ones.
All constants.
u=1, all constants.
Right, so that was the
free-free case in 1-D. Now,
I just want you to tell me
the same thing over here.
That equation does not
have a unique solution.
So it's a singular problem.
Here's the equation,
something u equals zero,
but you can tell me solutions
to that pure Neumann problem.
That are not zero.
So this is a problem where
there's a null space.
And what is the solution?
What's a solution to this?
To the Laplace's equation
in the inside and slope
zero all around the boundary.
There's a simple
solution to that one,
which is just like this guy.
And do you see what it is?
u equal constant, right.
So u equal constant.
So I'd like you to see the
whole picture connecting
with what we fully
understood in the 1-D case
for those matrices.
We don't expect to be able to
have a pure Neumann problem.
A totally free problem.
Because these, it'll
be singular and we'll
have to do something special.
So the point is that it
would be enough for me just
to fix that little bit.
If I just fix that little bit
and prescribe u=u_0 on a little
bit, I could make
the rest of it free.
But I can't make it all free.
OK.
So those are things which, just
to complete the big picture
of Laplace's equation.
OK, now I'm going
to turn to solving.
So now I want to solve Laplace's
equation and then we'll have,
because we have the
review sessions coming
on Tuesday and Wednesday of the
past, now we're looking future.
Forward.
Ready to look forward.
Laplace's equation.
On a square.
OK.
So let me draw this square.
Laplace's equation or
Poisson's equation.
In a square.
OK, I'm going to make it
the boundary conditions--
So I'm going to have a mesh.
This is going to be
finite differences.
Finite differences will
do fine on a square.
As soon as I draw
this curved region,
I better be thinking
about finite elements.
So that's what, today is
the, like, square day.
OK, so square day I could
think of finite differences.
I just draw a mesh,
let's make it small.
So this is all known.
These are all known values,
let me just say u is given.
On the boundary.
I'll do the Dirichlet problem.
So at all these mesh
points, I know u.
And I want to find u inside.
So I've got nine
unknowns, right?
Nine interior mesh points.
Three times three three.
So I've got nine unknowns,
I want nine equations
and I'm thinking here
about difference equations.
So let me write my
equation -u_xx-u_yy=f.
Poisson.
What finite difference--
I want to turn this
into finite differences.
That'll be my system
of nine equations.
And the unknowns will
be the nine values of u,
so these are unknown.
Right?
Those are the unknown.
OK, and I need equations.
So let me take a typical
mesh point, like this one.
I'm looking for the finite
difference approximation
to the Laplacian.
If you give me Laplace's
equation and I say OK,
what's a good finite
difference approximation,
that I can then put in
the computer and solve.
I'm ready to do it.
So what should we
do for this one?
For that term?
What's the natural,
totally natural thing
to do to replace-- the
finite difference replacement
of minus u_xx?
Second differences.
And with the minus sign
there, second differences
around this point will
be a minus one of there,
two of those, a
minus one of those.
That second difference in the
x direction is my replacement.
My approximation.
And what about in
the y direction?
Same thing.
Second differences,
but now vertically.
So now I have minus
one, two more,
that makes this guy a four.
And this is minus one.
And on the right hand
side, I'll take the value
of f at the center point.
Do you see that molecule?
Let me highlight
the molecule there.
Four in the center,
minus ones beside it.
Our matrix, we're going
to produce a KU=f matrix,
and what's the K going to be?
It's K2D.
Let's give a name.
A new name.
We've had K forever.
Let's have K2D.
And u is, so tell me now
again just so we got,
what size is K2D for
this particular problem?
What's the shape of it?
How many unknowns
have I got in u?
Nine.
Nine unknowns.
And notice, of course,
near the boundary,
if this was the-- Well
let me take the first one.
What does the very first
row of K look like?
If I number nodes like this.
So this will be node number one,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine.
So number one is sort
of close to a boundary.
So I have here a minus one,
a two, and this is gone.
That's like a column
of our matrix removed.
Like a grounded
node, or whatever.
But then I have the
vertical one minus one, two,
making this into a four.
And this guy will
also be removed.
So I think if I look at
K2D, it's nine by nine.
I don't plan to
write all 81 entries.
But I could write the first row.
The first row comes
from the first equation.
So the first row has an
f_1 on the right hand
side, f at this point.
And what do you see,
what's on the diagonal?
Of K2D?
Four.
And what's the rest of the row?
Well there's the next point
and it has a minus one.
And then this point is
not connected to that,
so it's a zero.
I'd better leave room
for nine by nine here.
Four, minus one, zero.
And now what about number,
the rest of the row?
So there's four is the
center, minus one, zero.
And now I come to
here, so what's
the next entry in my matrix?
Minus one.
We're multiplying the
unknown, the fourth unknown.
And what about the
rest of the row?
This guy is not connected
to five, six, seven, eight,
or nine.
So now I have zero,
zero, zero, zero, zero.
OK.
So that would be
a row, that would
be a row that's sort
of different because it
corresponds to a
mesh point that's
way over near the corner.
How about the fifth row?
What would be the fifth row of
K2D corresponding to this guy
that's right in the middle?
What's on the diagonal,
what's the 5, 5 entry of K2D?
Four.
Good.
I'm going to have a
diagonal of fours.
I'm going to have fours all
the way down the diagonal.
Because every point
the molecule is
centered at gives me the four,
and I just have a minus one
for its neighbor.
And this guy has
all four neighbors.
They're all alive and
well, so there's a guy,
this is the fifth row.
There's somebody right
next door on the left.
Somebody right next
door on the right.
And then do the other
minus ones go after that?
This is the whole point.
I want you to see how
this K2D matrix looks.
Because it's the one, it's
the equation we have to solve.
So we've got to know what
this matrix looks like.
So what's the point here?
Four, it's got a neighbor there.
This was unknown number five.
It's fourth unknown
and the sixth unknown,
what are the numbers
of these unknowns?
Two and eight.
So this guy is going to have a
minus one in the two position.
And then zero.
And this guy, it'll also have
a minus one, is that nine?
Yeah, do you see how it's going?
I have a diagonal, I have
five diagonals somehow.
I have diagonal, the
neighbor on the left,
the neighbor on the right,
the neighbor underneath,
and the neighbor above.
Across the street you could say.
So our matrix, this
very important matrix,
more attention has
gone into how to solve
this equation for that matrix
than any other single specific
example in numerical analysis.
It's just a model problem.
And what do I notice
about this matrix?
So now you see it's
got five diagonals.
But, and what's the big but?
The big but is that those
five diagonals don't run,
it's not just a band
of five because you
don't get to the one
up above until you've
gone all the way-- You
see the bandwidth is big.
If my matrix-- If this is one,
two up to n, and this is one,
two up to n, then how
many unknowns have I got?
Just think big now.
We're in 2-D, think 2-D. How
many unknowns have I got?
N was three in the
picture, but now you're
kind of visualizing
a much finer grid.
How many unknowns?
N squared unknowns, right?
One to N in each direction.
So we've got the matrix
of size N squared.
Way bigger, way bigger.
I mean if N was ten, our
matrix is of size 100.
And of course, that's
completely simple.
The real question is when N
becomes 1,000 and our matrix
is of size a million.
And those get solved every day.
So, question is how.
Actually this, for a
million by million matrix,
this fast Poisson solver that I
want to describe does it great.
Actually, so you can deal with
a matrix of order a million
without turning a hair.
OK now, but can we
understand that matrix?
So suppose N is 100.
Just to have us--
What's the story?
This matrix, then.
What's the size of that matrix?
Did I say 100?
Or 1,000, do you want
to think really big?
I guess I said 1,000.
To get up to a million.
OK, so N is 1,000,
so we have a 1,000
by 1,000, a million unknowns.
My matrix is a
million by a million.
Let me ask you this.
Here's the question
that I want to ask you.
What's the bandwidth?
How far from the main
diagonal out to the last-- out
to that minus one.
In other words, this is really
the full band of the matrix.
It's got a lot of
zeroes inside the band.
A whole bunch.
Maybe 990 something
zeroes in here.
And in here, and how far
is it from here to here?
1,000, right?
It's 1,000.
So the bandwidth is 1,000.
And what if I do
ordinary, so now I
want to begin to think how
do I solve this equation?
How do I work with that matrix?
And you have an
idea of that matrix?
It's a beautiful
matrix to work with.
It's very like
our K matrix; it's
just up to 2-D. In fact, it's
closely connected to our-- K2D
will be closely
connected to K and that's
what makes life possible here.
But suppose I had to
solve this equation.
Alright, so I give it to MATLAB
just as a system of equations.
A million equations,
a million unknowns.
So MATLAB takes a gulp
and then it tries, OK?
So ordinary elimination,
that's what backslash does.
By the way this
matrix is symmetric,
and, you won't be surprised,
it's positive definite.
Everything is nice
about that matrix.
In fact more than I've said.
OK, what happens if I do
elimination on that matrix?
How long does it
take, how fast is it?
Well, MATLAB will take
advantage, or any code,
will take advantage of
all these zeroes, right?
In other words, what do
I mean by take advantage?
And what do I mean
by elimination?
You remember I'm going to
subtract multiples of this row.
There'll be a minus one
below it on this guy.
This row that has some fours
and some minus ones, whatever.
Elimination, I'm subtracting
a multiple of this row
from this row to get that
minus one to be a zero, right?
I'm eliminating this
entry in the matrix.
This is ordinary LU, this
is ordinary LU of K2D.
I'm sort of thinking
through LU of K2D.
And what I'm going to
conclude is that there
ought to be a better way.
It's such a special
matrix, and it's
going to be messed up by LU.
And what do I mean by messed up?
I mean that all these great
zeroes, 990-something zeroes
there and there, inside the
band, are going to fill in.
That's the message,
if you want to talk
about solving large
linear systems,
the big issue is fill in.
It's a sparse matrix.
That's typical.
We have a local operator
here, so we expect
a very local, sparse matrix.
Large sparse matrices
is what we're doing now.
And the problem is that--
Zeroes here will never
get touched because we
don't need any elimination,
they're already zero.
But all this diagonal
of minus ones when we do
eliminations to make
those zero, then
some non-zeroes are going to
come in and fill in the zeroes.
So the work, how much work
would elimination be, actually?
We could even think about that.
Can I just give the result for
how much time would elimination
take?
Ordinary elimination.
So I have N squared
rows to work on.
N squared rows to work
on, and then the distance,
that distance was
what in terms of N?
The width there is?
N, right?
It was about 1,000.
So I get N numbers here and
I have to work on N numbers
below.
To clean up a column I'm working
with a vector of length N
and I'm subtracting
it from N rows below.
So cleaning up a column
takes me N squared operation.
The total then is N^4.
N^4, for elimination.
And that's not acceptable.
Right?
If N is 1,000, I'm up to 10^12.
So elimination is not a good
way to solve-- Elimination,
in this ordering, ha.
Yeah.
So can I tell you two
ways, two better ways
to deal with this problem?
So two better ways to
deal with this problem.
One is, and MATLAB have
a code that would do it,
one is to change from this
ordering one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine,
change to a different ordering
that had less fill-in.
So that's a substantial part
of scientific computing.
Is to re-order the unknowns.
To reduce the number of
wasted, fill-in things
that you have to
fill in, and then you
have to eliminate out again.
And I can get that N^4
down quite a bit that way.
OK, so that's a
topic of importance
in scientific computing.
Is given a large linear system,
put the rows and columns
in a good order.
OK, and that's something
you hope the machine can do.
The machine will have a record
of where are the non-zeroes.
And then so you run
the little, you really
run the program twice.
You run it once without
using the numbers.
Just the positions of
non-zeroes to get a good
ordering so that the
number of elimination steps
will be way down.
And then you run it with the
numbers in that good order
to do the elimination.
So that's a topic of,
one topic in this.
But.
Today's topic is using the
fact that this is a square.
That this matrix
has a special form.
That we can actually find its
eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
And that's what makes
a fast Poisson solver.
So that's the topic
of the lecture
and the topic of the
next section in the book.
And I will get
started on it now,
and then complete it Wednesday.
So I want to take this
particular K2D for a square
and show a different way to
solve the equations that uses
the fast Fourier transform.
When I see, when you see, a
regular mesh, regular numbers,
nothing varying,
constant diagonals,
think fast Fourier transform.
The FFT has got
a chance when you
have matrices like this one.
And this I want to
show you how it works.
I want to show you
the underlying idea,
and then we'll see the
details of the fast Fourier
transform in the
Fourier section.
So, of course, everybody
knows the third part
of this course, which
is coming up next week,
we'll be well into it,
is the Fourier part.
OK.
But I can give
you, because we've
seen the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues of K,
I can do this now.
Ready for the smart idea?
The good way, and it
only works because this
is a square, because the
coefficients are constant,
because everything's
beautiful, here's the idea.
OK.
Central idea.
The idea is, so I
have this matrix K2D
and I'm trying to solve a system
with that particular matrix.
And the fantastic
thing about this matrix
is that I know what its
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
are.
So let's suppose we know them.
So I know (K2D)y = lambda*y.
y is an eigenvector,
and remember
it's got N squared components.
Lambda's a number.
And I've got a whole lot of
these, y_k, lambda_k, y_k.
And I've got k going
from one up to N squared.
Now I want to use them.
I want to use them
to solve (K2D)u=f.
Let me say, it's totally
amazing that I would,
in fact this is the only
important example I know
in scientific computing,
in which I would use
the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of the matrix
to solve a linear system.
You see, normally you think of
eigenvalue problems as like,
those are harder.
It's more difficult to solve
this problem than this one.
Normally, right?
That's the way to
think about it.
But for this special
matrix, we can figure out
the eigenvalues and eigenvectors
by pencil and paper.
So we know what these guys are.
And that will give us a way
to solve a linear system.
So can I remember, this
is now central message.
What are the three steps
that to use eigenvectors
and eigenvalues in
solving linear equations,
in solving differential
equations, in solving
difference equations, they're
always the same three steps.
Can I remember what
those three steps are?
So step one, so I'm supposing
that I know these guys.
First of all, that's amazing.
To know them in advance.
And the second amazing
thing is that they
have beautiful structure.
And those facts make it
possible to do something
you would never expect to do.
Use eigenvalues for
a linear system.
So here's the way to
do it, three steps.
One, expand f as a combination
of the eigenvectors, c_1*y_1,
up to however many we've got.
We've got N squared of them.
Gosh, we're loaded
with eigenvectors.
Do you remember, this a
column of size N squared.
Our problem has size N squared.
So it's big, a million.
So I'm going to expand f
in terms of the million
eigenvectors.
OK.
So that tells me
the right hand side.
Now, you remember step two in
this one, two, three process?
Step two is the easy
one, because I want
to get, what am I looking for?
I'm aiming for, of course,
the answer I'm aiming for
is K2D inverse f.
Right?
That's what I'm shooting for.
That's my goal,
that's the solution.
So here I've got f in
terms of the eigenvectors.
Now I want to get, how do I get
u in terms of the eigenvectors?
Well, what's the eigenvalue for
the inverse, for K2D inverse?
Do you remember?
It's one over.
It's one over the
eigenvalue, right?
If this is true, then this will
be true with lambda_k inverse.
It's simple and I
won't stop to do it,
but we could come back to it.
So I know how to
get K2D inverse.
So that's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to divide, so
here's the fast step.
Divide c_k, each of
those c_k's, by lambda_k.
What do I have now?
I've got c_1/lambda_1*y_1
plus c_(N squared),
the last guy divided by
its eigenvalue times its
eigenvector.
And that's the answer.
Right, that's the
correct answer.
If this is the right hand side,
then this is the solution.
Because why?
Because when I multiply
this solution by K2D
it multiplies every
eigenvector by the eigenvalue,
it cancels all the
lambdas, and I get f.
Do you see-- I can't raise
that board, I'm sorry.
Can you see it at the back?
Should I write it up here
again, because everything
hinges on that.
The final, the answer
u, the K2D inverse f,
is the same combination
that gave f.
But I divide by lambda_1,
c_2 y, the second eigenvector
over lambda_2 and so on.
Because when I multiply by
K2D, multiplying each y,
each eigenvector will
bring out an eigenvalue,
it will cancel that and
I'll have the original f.
So do you see that
those are the steps?
The steps are, you have to
do a-- you could say it's
a transform into eigenspace.
I take my vector
in physical space,
it's got its N
squared component.
At physical points.
I express it in eigenspace.
By that I mean it's a
combination of the eigenvectors
and now the N squared
physical values
are N squared amplitudes, or
amounts of each eigenvector.
So that was a, that's the
Fourier series idea, that's
the Fourier transform idea,
it just appears everywhere.
Express the function
in the good basis.
We're using these
good functions.
In these good functions,
the answer is simple.
I'm just dividing by lambda.
Do you see that I'm just
dividing by lambda, where
if it was a
differential equation--
This is just what we did
for differential equations.
What did I do for
differential equations?
Do you mind if I just ask you?
If I was solving
dU/dt=(K2D)U. Starting from f,
start with U(0) as f.
I just want to draw the analogy.
How did we solve
these equations?
I expanded f in terms
of the eigenvector,
and then what was step two?
For the differential
equation, I didn't divide
by lambda_k, what did I do?
I multiplied by e^(lambda_k*t).
You see, it's the same trick.
Just get it in eigenspace.
In eigenspace it's like
one tiny problem at a time.
You're just following
that normal mode,
and so here instead
of dividing by lambda,
I multiplied by e^(lambda*t).
And for powers of-- For
K2D to the 100th power,
I would multiply by
lambda to the hundredth.
Here, I have K2D to
the minus first power.
So I'm multiplying by
lambdas to the minus one.
OK, and the key point is that
these c's can be found fast.
And this summing up
can be done fast.
Now that's what's
also very exceptional.
And that's where
the FFT comes in.
The fast Fourier transform is a
fast way to get into eigenspace
and to get back.
When eigenspace happens
to be frequency space.
You see that's the key.
In other words these y's and
lambdas that I said we knew,
these y's, the eigenvectors,
are pure sine vectors.
So that this is an expansion,
is a sine transform.
S-I-N-E. A pure sine transform.
And that can be done fast,
and it can be inverted fast.
So you see, what makes this
fast Poisson solver work,
is I have to know
eigenvectors and eigenvalues,
and they have to be fantastic
vectors like sine vectors.
OK, so I'll give you more, the
final picture, the details,
Wednesday and then move
on to finite elements.